welcome back so in the last lecture I
gave an overview of what we're gonna do
with the eigen system realization
algorithm we're gonna fit a linear model
a best fit linear dynamical system of
rank R to measured impulse response data
for something like you know an aerospace
system and I just wrote this down I kind
of did this pretty fast I said what is
an impulse response in you and what does
it elicit what kind of a response does
it excite and why and I wrote down the
answer but I figure I use this all the
time so maybe I should be a little bit
more explicit and walk you through
through these steps here
okay so so let's actually just do that
right now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
walk you through how to compute this
discrete time impulse response now I'm
using the identity matrix here for my
input because I might have multiple
inputs and I might excite them
individually i excite the first one the
second one the third one that would be
identity matrix Delta functions okay but
if you want to think about single input
and single output systems which can be a
little bit easier and that's probably
how I usually think about it so a single
input single output then B and C are
vectors and this would just be a one
okay so let's let's let's work through
this so what how do I do a discrete time
impulse response what I do is I
basically just go through a thought
experiment of what is U X and y at
various times okay so what is U what is
X and what is Y and we're gonna this is
important we're gonna use this basic
thought experiment more later when
things get complicated okay so at k
equals 0 U is equal to the identity we
assumed zero initial conditions so X Z
is equal to 0 and Y is equal to C times
0 plus D times I so Y is equal to the D
matrix pretty simple okay
now if K equals 1 so X at time 1 is B
times u at x 0 U at time 0 was I so X 1
is B plus my 0 initial condition so
at time okay so at time one my impulse
response turns off I'm no longer kicking
the system so it's I kicked it and now
at 0 but X goes from 0 to B now X is B
at time 1 and what is y well Y is C
times X right now plus D times 0 so Y is
C B let me just say that one more time
that was fast
y at k1 is C times X at k1 which is B C
times B plus D times 0 because U is off
now ok so Y is CB so I kick my system I
get an impulse 0 initial condition that
feeds directly through and this D matrix
then my impulse turns off and now all
that's happening is that impulse is
trickling through the dynamics and I'm
measuring that ok so now what at k2
again U is going to be 0 for all time
now dot 0 it's always 0 at k2 this is 0
and x2 is a times X 1 X 1 is B so it's a
times B a times B and then again all I'm
doing at time 2 is I'm measuring a times
B so Y is CA B maybe I will give myself
the room and actually do K equals 3 just
for grins ok so now I my state is a B I
multiply it by another a I get an a
squared B and I measure it C a squared B
and so on and so forth and you can very
clearly see the pattern here I get kind
of a to the M looks like K minus 1 B C a
to the K minus 1 B for a generic ok ok
and so that that's how I arrived at this
expression here of my impulse response I
I literally just did the thought
experiment of what what if this was
identity at time 0 and 0 for all future
time with initial conditions and you can
just follow through all of the math so
this is going to get a little hairier
what we're going to do the eigen system
realization assumes you can do an
impulse or
but that's hard to do in a lot of
systems so instead I might feed this
like a white noise input or some kind of
a pseudo-random input and try to back
out what the impulse response would have
been or back out these matrices and if
this you didn't drop off to zero all of
these expressions would get a lot more
nasty okay so this would no longer just
be a B this would be a B plus whenever u
is at this time it'll get really nasty
so I want you to think about it in a
simple case we're gonna come back to
this later for the case where these are
you know u 0 u 1 u 2 u 3 and we'll write
down the general expression okay but for
now for
Augen system realization algorithm we
assume we have an impulse response we
have this data these are measurements we
have actually what we have is this data
and this was the impulse so this is y0
y1 y2 I hope I'm doing this right y 3
dot dot this is the data that we have
for the eigen system realization
algorithm we literally just have this
data and then from this data we're going
to build a reduced order model a system
identification model okay
thank you